con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a hablar de la última semana
dedicada a la lucha contra la crisis
climática precisamente hoy viernes 23 de
septiembre los activistas salen a las
principales ciudades de todo el mundo
para exigir acciones que protejan a
nuestro planeta saludamos entonces a
Gustavo mañas él es el director adjunto
para América Latina y el Caribe el
programa de la ONU para el medio
ambiente Gustavo gracias a por estar con
nosotros está mañana el viernes en
directo América de Francia 24 hablemos
entonces de esta semana digamos contra
el calentamiento global contra la crisis
eclimática y las protestas que tienen
hoy Mejor dicho las manifestaciones que
tienen un lugar en las principales
ciudades del mundo lideradas por fire
for Future le preguntó durante todos
estos años desde 2018 que se creó este
movimiento eh Qué tanta presión y que de
qué ha servido esta presión que han
hecho estos grupos a los líderes
mundiales para que realmente tomen
acciones contra la crisis climática
definitivamente Freddy's era contribuido
a poner el cambio climático en el centro
de la agenda global
obviamente tener a unos hijos en casa
que están encima de ti recordándote la
importancia del cambio climático y no
como te va a afectar a ti a día de hoy
en tu bolsillo sino como les va a
afectar a ellos en sus vidas cuando
crezcan es importante y tiene que
continuar
justo le preguntó digamos que nos hace
falta No a nosotros como comunidad
internacional nosotros como ciudadanos y
también a los líderes mundiales para
realmente tomar en serio todo lo que nos
está pasando con nuestro planeta todos
estos cambios bruscos que hemos visto
con ciclones con lluvias con incendios
yo siento que si bien es cierto se
hablan de estos temas no en la comunidad
internacional también en la cop 26 que
se celebra en Escocia está con 27 que se
va a celebrar en Egipto pero finalmente
como que no se ven muy bien estas
acciones concretas en nuestros países
sobre todo de América la creatina
Pues mira tienes razón hay mucha
discusión mucho mucho Bla bla bla que se
dice pero realmente cuando llegamos a la
acción no vemos que esté pasando lo que
debería estar pasando para 2030 Si
queremos cumplir con el objetivo del
calentamiento a 1,5 grados que digamos
que es el aquel que nos saca del riesgo
dramático del cambio climático
tendríamos que estar reduciendo las
emisiones globales en casi un 50% para
el 2030 o sea en 8 años y según nuestros
cálculos estaríamos en un aumento de
emisiones de un 14% para esa época
entonces realmente
lo que significa esto es que la
implementación no está pasando nos
quedamos en el debate pero la
implementación a nivel nacional no está
pasando y la implementación a nivel
nacional en nuestros países de América
Latina pues es tiene que ver con temas
de cómo organizamos nuestro transporte
Cómo generamos energía Cómo generamos
comida la agricultura como la producimos
Porque esos son los sectores que generan
emisiones y ahí todavía estamos fallando
Gustavo Y es que también es yo pues
analizando un poco lo que hemos visto en
los últimos años y también yo creo que
lo hemos hablado en en nuestro programa
en nuestra mesa de trabajo y es lo
siguiente digamos la carrera del ser
humano también por conquistar el espacio
la luna ver otros planetas no y pues a
hacer absolutamente todo para mirar
afuera pero por qué no ponemos todas
esas energías todos esos recursos
también económicos que hacen falta para
hacer digamos esta transición de energía
de energía fósiles que usamos en este
momento a energías verdes a energías
limpias Y sostenibles ahora porque
estamos mirando afuera y porque no
estamos mirando en nuestra casa de este
momento o sea que que que que que están
pensando los líderes mundiales no O sea
como que digamos un poco de análisis
aquí crítica que yo siempre me han
preguntado por qué miramos afuera y no
nos apropia casa porque no miramos
adentro
pues no miramos adentro porque hay mucha
gente que estaría perdiendo dinero y
poder
si se toman las medidas que se deben de
tomar estoy pensando por ejemplo en la
generación de energía la explotación de
los combustibles fósiles como el
petróleo y el gas en nuestra región
ahora vemos un resurgimiento del gas
natural se piensa que es la panacea que
nos va a sacar de la pobreza vivir estos
altos precios internacionales del gas
por lo que está pasando en Ucrania que
tenemos que exportar más gas y se están
dirigiendo inversiones cada vez más
importantes a la explotación de estos
recursos cuando todos sabemos que Europa
lo que quiere es desconectar del gas
natural que lo que va a hacer es que en
los próximos años va a depender
exclusivamente de fuentes renovables y
sostenibles Y eso excluye el gas natural
pero pues debido a todos estos intereses
pues dedicamos recursos dedicamos
atención mal informamos hay campañas de
información muy grande es utilizando
redes sociales televisiones medios de
comunicación pagadas y orquestadas por
los intereses que te estoy mencionando
que lo que quieren es perpetuar un
sistema que nos va a llevar a todos a la
catástrofe gustado que sigue en materia
de la lucha contra el cambio climático
Hacia dónde vamos hay una una
oportunidad o ya estamos muy tarde
digamos obviamente ya está este límite
que pusimos de 1.2 grados pues no se va
a cumplir
mira cada
[Música]
centésima de grado en la lucha contra el
cambio climático importa cada acción
importa pero tiene que ir en la buena
dirección el secretario ejecutivo del
convenio de la ONU sobre cambio
climático el señor Simon Steel que por
cierto es un caribeño y que sabe muy
bien los impactos del cambio climático
en su piel ha hablado de que básicamente
nos quedan dos olimpiadas de aquí al año
2030 para revertir todo este panorama
dos olimpiadas es suficiente Si todos
nos concentramos en tomar las decisiones
adecuadas Y eso significa no apoyar más
exploración de petróleo y gas promover
el cambio de nuestras flotas de
transporte a movilidad eléctrica y hacer
una agricultura que en vez de depredar
el medio ambiente cortar bosques lo que
hace es vivir con la naturaleza y además
lo bueno de todo esto es que haciendo
todas estas acciones vamos a tener un
medio ambiente más limpio a través de
una mejor calidad aire a través de un
mejor ecosistema un ecosistema más
saludable vamos a generar más empleos
las energías renovables generan entre 3
y 4 empleos más que los combustibles
fósiles y vamos a generar un motor para
la economía que es lo que necesitamos
ahora mismo para salir de esta
grandísima crisis en la que estamos
viviendo Entonces por qué no lo hacemos